hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play dead
space 3 okay we just got done getting
some color I don't know I just heard it
oh hello
rowdy plating is tearing itself apart
the message is a warning to someone
named serrano on planet surface did you
find a way to decoder
yeah the encryption key is in the office
of Laura angstrom oh let me see if I can
find it yes
here she is I'll send it to your locus
well that's awfully handy except for the
whole grab plate mishap yeah that's not
good at all they really need to not why
don't roll into it you [ __ ] use your
locator use your locator there we go
okay that's a much better option than
going right into the grab plate nothing
like dying with style okay yeah maybe I
shouldn't have done whatever I did
exactly I'm what I did I'm not exactly
sure but carrying on hi I can barely
hear myself think Oh
I did finally pull the weapons out of
the bank so I got these um different
weapons now they're quite good as far as
I get whoa where do you all come from
holy hell
what's up [ __ ] having a chance to try
that out yet what the hell is that Wow
stop it all of you please
I don't know what that does it's kind of
like an electrical shotgun doesn't quite
kill them though
this whole gun is like electrified it's
kinda awesome
imma call this gun captain kick-ass or
something I don't know I'm not clever
with coming up with names on the spot
I'm not clever at all anyway so anyway
we need to go get to I'm actually gonna
turn down the volume of it ah no ha one
of those guys crawl now they kind of
hide their arm to not fear breath stop
it Jesus you a-holes are freaky I don't
like those guys they're kind of freaky
okay anyway collecting all the goodies
that exploded everywhere on the floor I
don't have a drive a keycard now I think
maybe yes I do I still don't have a
torque bar whatever that is torque
wrench torque wrench II wrench torque
wait a minute what oh here we go
hey Santos I'm sending you the
decryption key now I see it yeah hold on
I'll apply it to the message okey-dokey
yeah that helps
hydro said oh she uh-huh
must have been trying to hide her from
the execution order her research could
be the key to all of this okie-dokie
that makes sense
cleanse order if it would destroy such
an important secret maybe they panicked
remember they knew something we did mmm
Isaac thanks for looking into this it
could prove very useful good to hear
while heading back you've got a long
road ahead of us
Isaac out okie dokie first optional
mission down like a boughs and
apparently the optional missions are
where the scares are so I'll be sure to
hit all of them whenever I can
ah la dee da dee da dee floating in
space
I gotta admit how cool this is like
seriously I love big open environments
and the idea I've never seen it in
proper application but the idea of just
kind of exploring around space freeform
like this it's very appealing to me and
I imagine it's very appealing to a lot
of people because I love space
exploration and space games so this kind
of it's kind of awesome so anyway but
we've got a job to do so let's get to it
can I there we go got to click that
exact button there all right so now
we're headed to our primary objective
which I've kind of forgotten what it is
I think we're going to another ship to
try to get down to the planet see I need
to go to the Terra Nova get to the Terra
Nova that's me
commence travel got a nice little movie
sequence here to go our own way I'm
actually not sure how many optional
missions there will be I can't imagine
there would be that many because they
did a lot for this game I'm with the
co-op campaign being different from what
the normal campaign is I mean they made
like two separate games for this and
they're both pretty long from what I've
heard so I don't know either why should
be interesting to find out
I like dead space I like it a lot I mean
I don't mind that they've been trying to
be a bit more mainstream with less
scares it wasn't exactly the scares that
made me like the game anyway it was
mostly just said I really like the game
itself the gameplay and the story really
appealed to me
so I'm inside the Terra Nova yes
which way to the shell tacos you found
me in town records what did they say
uh-huh maybe that the shuttle was
decommissioned they were going to pop it
out great so basically nobody knows yep
there must be more detailed shipping
records somewhere I'll take a look
around this ship why did I get sent off
on my own anyway oh that's right because
uh uh I'm Isaac Clark and I'm a badass
I don't need anyone I already have a
suit on any there all right Chapter five
under way yeah Isaac Clark do your old
ship by myself what the hell I press
that everyone else needs help Roger
Clark can't figure out elevators good
okay so we're carrying on to do a
mission where we're looking for a type
of shuttle to get down to the place
where I ferry this shuttle off to the
other survivors who are just waiting
pretty in that ship that was infested
with monsters I bet they're all be dead
by the time I get to him
lobby freaking dog come on elevator I
thought they stopped at there we go
hello
Jesus okay maybe I was wrong under the
assumption that they would only have the
scary missions in the optional ones
warning power reserves are on standby
cargo functions are offline okay thank
you computer did I just pick up artifact
huh oh now this is the old hack that I
was used to
Oh God let's see if I remember it yeah
lag Emmaus and perfection is my name I
guess I got a bunch of different
minigames now here it looks like our
cells in the aft section of the ship of
course it is locators now okay just tell
me you'll get us to the nearest shipping
lane if we can get it space for the
again
judging from the diagnostic it's a real
piece of [ __ ]
boring get it - what can't we we're
swimming in a sea of spare parts I can
get it to fly okay you think you're a
better engineer than me oh my god Isaac
Clark best engineer in space you see
you'll see okay I'll show these monsters
first yeah this is this is looking a lot
more like the original dead space which
is really cool I mean I like it I did
have concerns that there would be a lot
less space fairness in the later ones
haha alright then thank you baby
get down Dodd's i got on there thank you
thank you very much
strafing is not Isaac strong suit
apparently but I've been collecting a
lot of materials I haven't crafted much
with them I may next time I hit a bench
try but oh hi
Nikes I wasted both of them yeah I'm out
of containers to launch what's over here
up hold on diabolical demons whoa hello
why can I never grab spikes anymore my
own strategy of grabbing the spikes
after I blow them off their body does
not appear to be working
no that's close range
damnit he's a holds their just piling up
all over the place
oh man come on
my reload rate sucks whoever said that
these weapons were ultimate I don't
really find him any better than the only
ones I had okay threat handled obviously
I am a dead space professional okay
let's try the skip grabbing a limb nope
okay Lim Lim any limb that's a dead baby
monster no no no no no oh come on
reload you [ __ ] there we go finally
mother [ __ ] I do not like what they
did with the weapons in this game I will
admit the customization is kind of cool
but in practical application I like the
old weapons better a lot better
single-use weapons
I mean combo weapons worked in pain
killer before as I can tell in practical
application I'd rather have four
different weapons that I can choose from
Vanette fred NNE what Wow an old
scavenger buy this will come in handy
will it what wait what alright then
scab
okay then i guessing this just finds
treasure and also it's a snarky pet
companion is there something here oh ha
wait no is there something here am i
just looking at nothingness what am I
looking at what am I looking at ah but
the car doesn't know what he's looking
at
I will punish you scavenger but okay
that's what you get for showing me
nothing looks like marker stuff is that
it oh I got it what return them to the
boom wha wha wha what do I just leave it
there this is a confusing addition to
the game that doesn't need to be there
seems like a waste of time and effort
and energy to find stuff that I could
just you know walk towards and find on
my own don't need a robot whatever hello
ain't you ugly hey spike hey spike miss
spike Holly help spike
[ __ ] you dammit odd man I swear I think
I'll just stick with standard plasma
cutter for now on that's what I like
standard plasma cutter am I going
backwards or forwards I don't even know
okay hi bye alright no I said no where'd
your bomb going
no I am us Clark don't have any mercy
for aliens
zombies alien zombies duh okay so that
yeah that's what they do to the bodies
no no no no no ghetto Chuck on thank you
ah they're on me [ __ ] use your house cat
thank you Jesus
right oh yeah your spiky go die in a
fire you [ __ ]
he's not dead yet how can he not be
tapped yet [ __ ] man Jesus Christ on a
cracker
the weapons in this game suck and I'm
out of health your son two [ __ ] I
hate you so much
that man named Nana man weapons didn't
even suck this much in the demo what the
hell happened in the in the meantime
what the hell oh no no no no I should
know
no it's gonna I'm not handling this
situation well hey I remember you
you got uglier somehow pick up the spike
and spike you [ __ ] I'm almost out of
ammo as well that's it huh Wow what you
can't just do that you can't just do
that you can't automatically get up I'm
out of status no [ __ ] off you go to hell
and you die
give me your spike so I can spike you
knock you down give me up take bad
I am so boned
mother what no good god I can't use my
Kinesis effectively I'm out of ammo I'm
out of help this is full is beyond pull
is like turbo bull just just pull give
me that so I can and you're not dead are
you and now you are okay now I've got
this I'm gonna keep that stop you or
your goodies which you don't have any
you have no goodies I hate my life
I hate my life ah I'm Isaac Clark
there's socks I shouldn't have wasted
all Miami on that damn optional mission
all right come on yes oh there's a
stasis recharge right there
well open the lockers sitting here
spamming my used key nothin happenin
here they are yes please die stasis so I
can dismember give me that's not a spike
what the hell no no give me that
give me that oh these sons of [ __ ]
want to go through the wringer huh who's
out there
screw the gun then gun sucks except for
the shotgun I should have just put the
damn shotgun on my other frickin gun
here duh ah dah you saw the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] now you saw
the [ __ ] ass [ __ ] mother stop shove a
fist up enjoy your [ __ ] mother [ __ ]
you have a stasis Rock go to hell I
messed [ __ ] Jesus Christ one chance of
stasis Mother of God [ __ ] yeah yeah
I'm not doing so well
who else is out there I don't remember
Necromorphs ever having a voice god damn
I'm like like please report to cradle
operations to remove the apology okay
yeah all right okay man guys something's
blocking the tram system fatal op should
be nearby you can see the tracks from
there
Thanks buckle I'll check it out yeah
thanks buckle dick got you got you go no
I'm not bad at dead space I've actually
made I've actually did quite well
playing dead space on impossible who's
up there
who's gonna surprise shove a fist on my
ass who is up there who are you
I need help
that is ammo not else yeah I'm not I'm
not I'm not exactly the worst oh not
again not again not again not again die
are those little things actually talking
do they have voices oh not you just let
me dismember you quietly which is not
working there we go
you die nice and easy and then we will
have a fine day but I still haven't
gotten any health which I need ah are
the pork sick of your [ __ ]
nothing please pop through the vent in
the ceiling if you do I will die I'm
running on my last leg here Isaac Clark
can't take much more [ __ ] no open oh
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me I can
hit that button from way of [ __ ] over
here but wherever I wanna head it that
got [ __ ] da match and now oh I
couldn't hit it right away then
hi the [ __ ] was that
Oh bench I don't even care anymore bench
I'm doing just fine
bench these are coffee ok oh do you
someone left a bunch of cargo on the
tracks
can you clear it I should be able to
I'll get to that shuttle and a half
section one way or nothing
ok what am i doing now what the what
wait what wait I don't understand the
puzzle stop introducing a bunch of
strange puzzle aspects I don't
understand the puzzle what the [ __ ] is
the puzzle what what is what what uh
what's the puzzle
what's the puzzle explain it to me
before you're an ass oh god what the
[ __ ] is the puzzle I'm ok with solving a
puzzle if I know what I'm trying to
accomplish what am I trying to
accomplish what the hell am I trying to
accomplish am i this there we go mother
of [ __ ]
I need ah what does this have to do with
dead space okay alright whatever let's
just get it done
skit done so we can get another [ __ ]
executive that has nothing to do with
the plot there we go just got to fit the
garbage together man
this got fed together I didn't even know
I was looking at garbage whatever
no you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm very angry
I'm very angry
I'm very angry very very angry I should
not be this angry playing a game that I
enjoy that fit together right there yeah
I shouldn't I shouldn't be it's not fair
it's not fair to me
I'm sure you're all laughing at it but
it's not fair to me girl like it's like
the most strangely inappropriate puzzle
I've ever seen in my life huh I don't
even see the connection here what is the
connection here I couldn't even see that
coming wait why is that that's that was
the does the uber morph cargo Fulton Bay
for containment breach detected
biological anomalies are present oh good
good couldn't make it too easy on me
hello hi was that the UM no that's just
a normal ahh ha ha ha I froze its
projectile in midair
nope ah [ __ ] mess give me that stasis
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up mother [ __ ] I
will beat the [ __ ] out of you I'm out of
[ __ ] I'm so boned I'm melting in front
of a eyelets on behind me and I melted
it come from behind me they come from in
front of me they don't give me a chance
I hate my life hey my life life of which
I hate this is it
I will not try to melee them either in a
personal vendetta that I need to solve
come on pop out of there come on I know
you're in there I know you're in there
come on out
oh you're not gonna play today there you
are I was wondering when you were gonna
yes the wall is exactly what I intended
to hit
nope you stay there and you want them
but ah mother [ __ ] these god damnit
stasis does not last long either I'm
gonna kill myself and are you with me
ah I'm so angry Oh mother [ __ ] hell I
hate my life man Jesus Christ I wish I
just want better weapons screw this I'm
uh what the [ __ ]
let me out let me out let me out let me
out go go go down open it back up you
[ __ ]
Oh [ __ ]
okay so I'm in cradle ops now that's
dad's that's good that's good man Searcy
I should not be this aggravated playing
a game I supposedly enjoy module here I
found this recording when I was stuck on
Titan Station
what okay I already know this you can
use it I don't need to see that again I
don't need to watch I've seen it I try
it for some reason it doesn't work in
Dead Space 3
man I swear they intentionally made
those spitters with spitters the new
most aggravating [ __ ] in the world I
swear I swear like I'm trying to have
some fun here I'm trying to have fun
I'm not even playing on the hardest
difficulty of which I can do just fine
it's just ease damn guns are not what I
remember is [ __ ] I wish I wish
yeah there I knew it I knew that was the
[ __ ] goober Marvin Oh lost an arm I
feel so bad
this one's regenerating yeah I know I'm
not what not killing it my way you do
both you just just get out of my way you
can't climb stairs I can or ladders or
whatever not even gonna waste the ammo
because give me that ah about that dog
what the [ __ ] dunno
I don't have any spaces rod Isaac run
I'm a stasis Jesus Christ go go go go go
go
[ __ ] up slow now now yes out of
a [ __ ] no Vince
[ __ ] [ __ ] at least I got a
cinematic death that time the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh is he right by me oh oh you put me
where you wait where am I even going
what what is this [ __ ] did I even come
through here
what is this I remember coming through
here give me help where what am i oh oh
I wasn't supposed to go no I didn't even
know where drop me off I'm so confused
I was so damn confused what is it doing
that is a leg I swear this gaem used to
automatically help you by picking up the
useful items of which it no longer does
why would I want an arm when I'm trying
to stab this guy in the face
slow your horses that is gonna arrive
shortly
what well there's more than one of them
that is [ __ ] what this doesn't make
any sense this makes no sense why is
there more than one give me a smile ah
Wow
why the [ __ ] where did it come from
bali-ba what there's two of them why are
there two Jesus Christ this is like the
most [ __ ] I've ever seen in my
entire life I don't even understand how
son of a [ __ ] where did he even come
from there is no vent here where did he
oh I see up there I don't know how or
why but I guess it doesn't matter what
matters is that I am boned eternally
just looking out for the second one
which I assume is gonna be coming any
moment now
not you but I guess I can kill you as
well
what's that oh is that a health kit
think that might have been a health kit
no it was not it wasn't at trim will
arrive shortly please stand oh those no
no no still not the second one the thing
I am worried about that's what I'm
worried about
oh god damn it
ah god damn it mother [ __ ] Jesus
Christ oh hi I can't even get a break
you know what oh I'm I can't I can't I
can't keep this up I can't do it I can't
do it
I can't do it I just can't do it because
right now I'm far too aggravated far too
aggravated I'm far too lacking resources
and it's just like driving me insane so
I need to stop it in his time anyway so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I apologize for raging so much even
though I know you enjoyed it so thank
you everybody so much for watching and
click the annotation for more videos it
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
wrong